here's the game we really want to talk
about this is a game
that
deserves some close study some spending
some time on and you will if you said it
closely be able to beat
everyone you play unless they have
invested enough time to learn what you
have learned it is simply the very same
game
but we play it on three boards instead
okay so now the rules here
are that a player on his move his or her
move can put an x on any of the boards
you can choose whichever board you like
now as players
put x's on the boards eventually one of
the boards is going to get three in a
row and then that board but only that
board is declared dead at that point you
can't make any more moves then on that
particular board but
you play on on the remaining two again
on one of the two remaining boards once
three in a row is made that board dies
is no longer available for play and then
you're left with whatever configuration
of x's may be on the third board and you
complete that board then whoever makes
three in a row on the final board loses
the game okay this game is difficult to
master
but it can be mastered starting from
this position
you do want to move first
now in practice
if you learn
how to play this game you can even let
the your opponent move first because you
usually know enough you'll see a mistake
they make and you'll be able to overcome
that but if you're playing someone who
happens to be really good then you do
want to make sure that you move first
then there's another strange twist to
this game that on three boards it
actually doesn't even matter
what move you make all the first moves
are winning you can move wherever you
want and it still is a winning position
for you so you can pretend to be very
magnanimous and say brady
absolutely please just choose any cell i
will accept that as my winning as my
move you don't say winning move you say
i will accept that as my move and then
we can play the game
so this is a nice trick you can play
just when you're getting started and in
general you remember on one board it was
the first player who wanted to go and on
three boards it's also the first person
if you were to play the same game i'm
not recommending it but if you were to
play it on five you would also want to
move first and on boards if you have two
four six sports you don't want to move
first you want to move second now i have
to be completely honest with you in
order to play well and to
be absolutely certain no one will ever
beat you you are going to have to know
certain configurations of x patterns on
the board and have them memorized
and it's not the just the pattern you
need to memorize but you'll need to
memorize a particular
variable or symbol or fingerprint for
each one then what you need to do is
multiply those symbols together which
are just sort of
like algebra things that you learn about
in school
and then reach a certain safe
configuration value
um that's that's basically all there is
to it the rest of it is just
memorization this is small so i need to
put on my glasses it is daunting um but
it's not quite so daunting as it looks
this is a list of all the ways you can
put up to nine x's on a tic tac toe
board it turns out there are exactly 102
such ways no one turn off the video
okay there are 102 of these but there
are a lot of them that
are very easy to remember for example if
you look at the ones at the bottom here
you'll see there are ones here that are
all given the number one or the identity
we're going to be multiplying these
things together so the ones that already
have completed rows of x's they're
already dead boards and so those are
like the identity when we're multiplying
things together if a board is already
dead it doesn't matter so it's just the
number one you don't need to memorize
dead boards because you look at it and
it's already has an x through it you
don't even have to remember those so the
only ones you need to
focus on
are the ones where there's still play
available and for each of those it's
going to be a symbol and the symbol is
just going to be like a single algebraic
term like it might be an a it might be a
b squared it might be a bc it might be a
d squared or so on and that's what all
you have to remember
plus a couple things having to do with
reducing words and simplifying them let
me just show you some typical
fingerprints okay one of them is say
just an x in the corner that happens to
be the identity or the number one it's a
fingerprint which does nothing it's the
same as a deadboard if there's only one
thing in the corner you can ignore it
another dead board
is the one where the x is here this is
also a one
all right uh we want to be systematic
here so what is the last one brady what
would the last one be an x in the middle
it would be an x in the middle exactly
so if we have this one that one is
slightly different this i am going to
call c squared there are certain
positions that come up a lot more than
others when you look at the big table
you say oh i can't do this it's too hard
well no it's not too hard you just have
to play more and just kind of get used
to it
okay so let's take some typical ones
that come up all the time okay so one of
them is this one
this comes up a lot
and this happens to be b squared
okay that's that's a good one one of
them is when you have two x's on the
corners or opposite corners like this
and a
that comes up a lot the one that has
ones like this and that one also happens
to be an a okay let's say you go to the
trouble of learning all of these
fingerprints how is that going to help
you
well let's see let's start a
hypothetical game let's say that
let's say let's say that i've made this
first move x i look at this position and
i like it why do i like it
because
this happens to be a one this one
happens to be a c
and this one happens to be a c and when
i multiply these two together
in my head i get c squared and c squared
happens to be one of the
magical
polynomials or just monomials that i
want to leave in every position to make
sure i win c squared so you have to
remember i like c squared so what are
the other ones there's c squared
there's also the letter a there's b
squared and there's b times c and that's
it those are the those are the four you
need to remember those four ones if you
make a move so that the fingerprints
multiply to one of those possibilities
then there's no way for your opponent to
regain control you will still win the
game so at each stage you are always
trying to find a move that equals an a a
b c
a b squared or a c squared well let's
say our opponent decides they're free to
of course to move on any of these three
boards but let's say that my opponent
decides to move on the same one here and
moves here
okay what's a good reply here well
there's actually a quite nice reply
remember c squared was itself a good
move and if i kill this board by moving
here then it's completely out of play
and i'm only going to be left with these
two so that's going to be a c squared
too boom i do this i'm still under
control and i've killed one board also
so we're getting closer to winning also
when you're playing this game you tend
to look first at the options that
involve killing boards right it's better
you know think of it like a samurai
it's better to kill your opponent sooner
rather than later because if you let
them linger you know they may rise up
and you know all of a sudden surprise
you okay so i always look first is there
a good move that involves killing
something that's already on the board so
now let's say my opponent plays to
uh shall we say let's play here
okay so that one if you remember that's
a one now so i cross out this c and i
make this a one
now we multiply these two together it's
no longer c squared it is now
multiplying to c that's bad
that is bad that is not one of the i
mean it's
it's good for me because i need the uh
if it were a c squared that would be
because i'd have no winning move right
remember that's what i'm trying to do to
someone else but if it's a c i know
there is a winning move i just need to
figure out what is the winning move uh
another one that i've happened to
memorize and uh and it's a very simple
one is just that
if you have
two
like this one in the center and then one
on the edge connected it can't even it
can be on the diagonal or oriented
however you like that's always a b
okay so this is a b
that's a b
and you know in all of course all the
reflections and rotations and so on
these are all b's all right okay
all right so that's what i'm going to do
here i'm going to
change this away from a 1 it's no longer
a 1. it's now a b and now i have b times
c and that's one of the magic ones so
now i'm no longer at c now i'm at bc and
i'm still happy i still i'm still
winning i left my opponent facing a
losing position a bc now let's say what
do they do
well one thing they could do is
you know i killed a board maybe they're
dumb enough to you know kill a board too
so let's say that they kill this one
boom okay so now this is now what it's
the identity it's dead so it's just the
number one right remember you know from
algebra you multiply by one has no
effect so all the dead boards they're
always one now you've got a a c well
we've already talked about this haven't
we what is the winning move when we have
one board
right what is the winning move the
winning move is not to move on the edge
remember it's to move in the middle so
we do this
okay
now we still have to win this
but we know how to do that too
we just do the knights move strategy
okay so my opponent
my opponent might move here
i move a knight's move away here
now my opponent maybe they move
here
i move a knight's move away there
and now my opponent
is dead
and i have one demonstrating
my mastery
that i hope all the number file
video people will also become my rivals
although i don't look forward to it of
tic tac toe on three boards in missouri
play so good luck to everybody
this video and all number five videos
you watch are supported by the
mathematical sciences research institute
here in berkeley california that's the
building behind me if you'd like to find
out more about the mathematics and the
mathematics outreach that's done here
check out the links in the video
description